[Musique]
ensemble ils rédigent des projets
professionnels
nous sommes à l'espace insertion sud à
mulhouse
la jeune femme vient de rentrer en
france après plusieurs années passées à
travailler à l'étranger en recherche
d'emploi sans ressources depuis son
retour elle demande le revenu de
solidarité active
son dossier sera traité ici et
aujourd'hui pour finaliser sa demande
elle a rendez vous pour un entretien
avec une travailleuse sociale
lors de ces entretiens on parle
formation recherche d'emploi mais aussi
depuis peu de bénévolat c'est des
entretiens d'instruction du rsa ou en
fait en même temps un bilan socio
professionnelles au cours de ce bilan
socio professionnelles ont fait l'étude
de son parcours de ses de ceux de son
parcours professionnel de son parcours
de vie et en même temps on leur propose
le bénévolat comme futures actions
d'insertion s'ils le souhaitent
le bénévolat est une action d'insertion
au même titre que une formation pour des
personnes qui ne peuvent pas retrouvé
tout de suite un emploi mais ça peut
leur permettre aussi de d'utiliser le
bénévolat sur leur curriculum vitae pour
montrer aussi qu'ils ont été actifs
pendant un certain temps et qui ne sont
pas rester sans rien faire pendant une
période toute une période d'inactivité
donc soit dans votre cas vous avez coché
la case sur le bénévolat que vous en
aviez déjà fait donc c'était un niveau
de médecins sans frontières
oui la proposition de bénévolat
rencontre un certain écho auprès de
l'autre allocataires en effet la jeune
femme a déjà effectué des missions pour
médecins sans frontières dans différents
pays à travers le monde
ça peut être un premier pied à l'étrier
pour aider à retrouver un emploi
elle rsa et bénévolat une histoire
compliquée dans le haut rhin
lorsque le dispositif est évoqué pour la
première fois en 2016
il donne lieu à de vifs débats je pense
qu'il ya eu une annonce plutôt
maladroite au départ un de l'objectif
qui a toujours été un objectif très
positif mais c'est vrai que on est parti
d'une idée
tiens ben sept heures de bénévolat
obligatoires ces trois mots ont tout de
suite fait phosphorer tout un tas de
de gens mais dès l'origine dès la genèse
il n'était pas question de d'obligations
et l'idée de sept heures ou de quelques
heures c'était juste une idée lancée
comme ça qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et
ce sont les groupes de travail qui était
chargé de trouver la solution
intéressante idéale elle n'existe pas
mais intéressante
les bénéficiaires du rsa sont
accompagnés à partir du premier jour où
elles entrent dans le dispositif et
jusqu'à ce qu'elle le quitte et
lorsqu'elle signe le contrat qui leur
permet ensuite de toucher l'allocation
dans ce contrat nous proposons de faire
des heures de bénévolat à partir de ce
moment là nous lui proposons d'aller
consulter les différentes offres qui se
trouve sur la plateforme et qui émanent
d'associations ou voire de communes donc
nous mettons ces personnes en contact
avec ces associations ces structures ni
tout à fait donc il y aura une réunion
d'information prochaine mise en place
depuis quelques mois le dispositif se
déploie petit à petit déjà une
plateforme internet sur le site du
conseil départemental recense quelques
700 offres de bénévolat
un genre de bons coins de l'associatif
pour faire se rencontrer offre des
associations et demandent des
allocataires initiative sorti tout droit
de la concertation organisée par le
département pour construire le
dispositif rsa bénévolat on a eu des
associations du monde du sport du monde
de la culture du monde de l'insertion
on a eu des élus évidemment on a eu des
allocataires très important pour qu'il
puisse aussi donner leur point de vue
on a vraiment eu tout un tas de
partenaires différentes que nous avions
sollicité qui se sont proposé d'emblée
et nous avons créé des groupes que nous
avons souhaité équilibré c'est à dire
avec des représentants de chaque
catégorie de personnes dans chaque
groupe
retour à l'espace insertion pour un
nouvel entretien
installé en france depuis 16 ans n'at il
est et traductrice indépendante son
activité connaissant des hauts et des
bas elle fait la demande du rsa
elle est aussi bénévole depuis onze ans
le secours populaire de mulhouse le
bénévolat comme vecteur d'insertion
elle connaît bien pour moi c'était une
bonne expérience parce que ça me
souviens quand je suis venu en france je
parlais pas du tout français à quelques
mots en anglais mais français pas du
tout et là ça me souviens que je suis
allé demander dans toutes les
associations tout de suite et je suis a
pris par le secours populaire et ça m'a
pris surtout j'ai appris pas mal de j'ai
appris le français parce que j'ai eu
toujours de contact avec le genre les
représentants mais tous les allocataires
des minima sociaux rentrer dans le
dispositif ne vais pas une expérience
associative avant qu'on leur propose
c'est le cas de françoise qui découvrent
l'engagement bénévole grâce à sa
référente et c'est elle qui m'a
communiqué l'adresse de la maison de
retraite et je suis allée de moi même à
la maison de retraite
je me suis présenté et puis le courant
est passé
elle m'a tout est dit vous commencez le
lendemain je me rappelle plus je suis
quand est-ce que j'ai commencé mais
c'était dans la semaine même et voilà
j'y suis depuis juin et ce bénévolat bon
est tombé pile poil donc puisque bon
c'est quand même compliqué pour moi de
trouver un travail à temps plein autant
faire du bénévolat quoi voilà je me
permets de vous poser cette question là
parce que en fait le département du haut
rhin a mis en place le bénévolat pour
les bénéficiaires du rsa 1 pour
valoriser savoir-faire les connaissances
et compétences des personnes donc pour
l'heure 500 allocataires sont rentrés
dans le dispositif et les premiers
retours semblent très positif on a
des personnes qui nous ont dit moi ça
m'a permis de sortir de chez moi de
rompre l'isolément
ça m'a permis aussi de d'accéder à une
formation
ça m'a permis de voir ce qui était aussi
le monde des associations
je ne connaissais pas donc c'est pour
une fois que les personnes sont rentrées
dans la démarche
il trouve vraiment positif d'être
d'avoir intégré le bénévolat je vais
stipulé que vous êtes aussi déjà bien
impliqué dans le bénévolat mais ceux qui
en parlent le mieux
ce sont encore les bénévoles vous le
donne en exemple je m'insère qui est en
france depuis cinq ans et tout de suite
le premier semaine que elle est venue en
france
le seule chose que je fais j'ai présenté
au secours populaire
et depuis cinq ans elle fait même chose
que moi et moi toujours je suis
traductrice dans une centre de
demandeurs d'asile est tout de suite
quand je vois des gens qui sont fermés
qui sont ils passent leur temps sans
rien faire mais je propose tout de suite
d'aller demander de faire ça ya pas mal
d'associations même à mulhouse ne parte
ou qu'il a vraiment besoin de nous et
quand on n'a pas de travail c'est bien
si on passe quelques temps pour aider le
gens qui a besoin de noms que rester
sans rien faire